تزين صورة البابا
فرنسيس الجدران المتفجرة التي تحمي
كنيسة سيدة النجاة في بغداد ، وقد تكون
رسائل
الأخوة واجهة
للذكرى المريرة لأسوأ مذبحة على الإطلاق
للمسيحيين في بغداد ،
كل واحدة من هذه المربعات الحمراء
تمثل المكان
الذي مات فيه شخص ما في أكتوبر 2010  قُتل
ما مجموعه
58 شخصًا في الهجوم
الإرهابيون من الدولة الإسلامية في
العراق ، حيث
اقتحم تنظيم داعش الكنيسة خلال قداس المساء الذي
كان لويس كليماس بالداخل
ويتذكر أن المهاجمين أوضحوا
هدفهم كان شريرًا
لقتله  يقول
إنهم اعتبروا كل شخص في
الكنيسة كافرًا
يستحق الموت وفقًا لـ CNN's أوتاوا
دامون من الكنيسة في
أعقاب ذلك مباشرة
عندما اقتحم المهاجمون
نصف المصلين
عادوا إلى هذه الغرفة محاولين
الحفاظ على سلامتهم ،
لقد قاموا بتحصين الباب ولكن
كان المهاجمون يلقون
بالقنابل اليدوية وهناك دماء على الجدران
هنا
ترك الناس  الشموع
طوال المساء
هنا تم إخبارنا بالبقايا عندما
انفجرت إحدى القنابل اليدوية وتناثرت
جميع السقوف والجدران
لتتناثر مع
شمامسة الدم يظهر لنا بالضبط المكان الذي
كان
يرتعد فيه على الأرض مع ابنه
وعشرات الآخرين.
مختبئًا أثناء الهجوم شظية
مزقت رأسه
بقينا هنا لمدة أربع ساعات في حالة من الرعب
والخوف يتذكر
أننا استسلمنا للمصير ووضعنا
حياتنا في أيدي مريم العذراء ،
ويظهر مقطع فيديو فزع
وصدمة بعد لحظات من
مناهضة العراق.  - اقتحمت قوات الإرهاب
الكنيسة وكانت المذبحة بمثابة
القشة التي قصمت ظهر البعير
لكثير من مسيحيي بغداد
منذ الهجوم الذي تركه الجميع تقريبًا ،
يقول نادك أنور ،
أحد الناجين قبل أن أقيم القداس ثلاث
مرات في
الصباح ومرتين في المساء الآن ، هناك
يوم واحد فقط هائل.
انحسر شبح الإرهاب في
الوقت الحالي ، لكن الفساد والشلل السياسي
والفوضى والتفرقة المتصورة
تركت الإتصالات المسيحية.  الوحدة
بحاجة ماسة للمساعدة ، نحن بحاجة إلى من يقف معنا ، يقول
الشماس كليمنس
لأننا نعيش في غابة ، غابة
تسيطر عليها
الوحوش السياسية ،
غابة بحاجة إلى القديسين بن ويدمان CNn
بغداد.